au mexique avec mes amis et j'ai
rencontré une fille qui est venue et
elle a dit j'ai une méduse qui m'a piqué
non si dans l'aude villa est venu en
plus il faut sucer quand la méduse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
exceptionnel cela c'est vrai qu'on a un
petit peu triste et ses méchants paul il
avait toujours le sourire je me sens moi
dès qu'il voyait ma gueule il fait
rigoler gradina
j'ai un regret je vous lis et que cet
été
je fallait le boire
ouais optique qu'il soit rigolade à
toc toc badaboum
non
messieurs
timalo
alors il faut que tu sois un [ __ ]
raisonnable c'est une phrase qui a
énormément fait parler ce week end voilà
il a entendu ce genre de propos et
matthieu delormeau nous à dix juste
avant la pub attention je vais me faire
insulter suit ce qui se passe pour ça
fait 20 ans que la télévision montrent
des homosexuels totalement caricaturaux
ça fait 12 ans qu'on demande à danse
avec les stars que deux garçons dansent
ensemble et quand deux garçons dans son
ensemble qui dansent sébile al hassani
j'ai rien contre millas la ceni mais
pardon un mec qu'a une perruque et des
fossiles je ne me reconnais pas dans ce
style de gaines chacun mais chacun a son
style et la télévisi d'avoir ce style
prennent-ils à la cei parce que c'est
une star parce qu'ils arriveront à
l'oreille parce que
non là je suis pas d'accord que les gens
que tu vois la télévision se disent
tiens je reconnais le guet parce que
zaugg est normal on sait pas qu'il est
gay on a plein de gay comme laurent
ruquier il est pas tout marc olivier
fogiel ton ami il n'est pas tout le
match ça les regarde le problème c'est
que c'est toi qui nous pousse à faire
des listes en charge de la non je te le
redis je suis choqué que dans danse avec
les stars pardon celui qui danse avec un
garçon cette année soit un gain gay qui
soit extrêmement caricaturale et c'est
facile c'est pas pour ça qu'il a été
choisi c'est vrai que l'animal on va
sentir depuis 30 ans et plus la cage aux
folles que les gens demandent que
quelqu'un de normal et cinq jours ça je
te rejoins complaire si absolument
absolument absolue mais la cage
en fait que ça rajeunit le vagin genre
c'est trop bien normand j'ai de la
chance c'est vraiment beau à
saint-georges pas les lèvres pourquoi
qui dépasse mais il faut l'entretenir
du coup c'est trop bien genre la passe
comme si j'avais tous en dehors
évidemment que c'est dangereux de dire
des choses comme ça parce que d'abord de
comparer de dire cavasin de deux ans
pour une femme de 20 ans et c'est
formidable ça ment ça me met mal à
l'aise parce que je me dis que
évidemment ça va peut-être réveiller des
instants pédophiles mais si pardon
excusez moi il n'y a rien de normal
quand pour un type de 20 ans et plus de
troupes d'avoir envie d'avoir une femme
12 ans pardon mais si rajeunir son vagin
et dire avoir un vagin de 12 ans pour
vous c'est un appel au viol posez-vous
des vraies questions dans vos têtes
c'est bouclé c'est le finir c'est que
c'est vous qui avez un problème associé
la pédophilie un vagin de 12 ans se
trouve que vraiment c'est extrêmement
grave alors la tête de ce qu'ils font
c'est un mal bien au vu de la polémique
maeva elle s'est excusée elle a réagi un
jour plus tard regardez je tiens à
m'excuser parce que je me suis très mal
exprimé faut savoir que voilà parfois
quand je parle l'info passe pas par le
cerveau elle passe directement par la
mouche qui était très choquée par ces
propos parce que je pense que ça détruit
complètement le rapport cas qu'on les
jeunes filles avec leur corps mais aussi
les garçons parce qu'il faut pas emmener
cas les gars ici qui sont aujourd'hui
obsédé par cette représentation du corps
de la femme parfaite et pardon excusez
moi à 12 ans hier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de qui
je préfère des femmes de l'émission
break away with me viennent surtout
[Applaudissements]
petits détails anecdotes savoureuses
on vous met loge la loge se faire
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon on a cloud et
saas et bien c'est donc maintenant et on
vous a vu ma fille non quelqu'un m'a dit
derrière en passant appuyer sur le
bouton ac a sonné
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une suggestion capillaire vous faut
garder là tu ferais mieux de l'arrêté
toile
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà sur youtube sa chaîne c'est un
truc c'est un carton de fou son clip me
limite j'ai vu des milliers de fois
bossi il a été vu 60 millions vu
[Applaudissements]
chacun de ces sons cartonne pas besoin
de toi je pense qu'il parle de vous
ces sorties samedi il est déjà numéro 5
des tendances il cumule plus de trois
millions quatre jours
[Musique]
dgo
comme tous ces la plage à marina va
casser des lobbys
[Musique]
duo avec une grande star de la télé
j'en vois pas une fille
je parle de ses mixes et qui séduit non
monsieur je suis trop jeune
lui qui s'est mis vous êtes j'avais fait
pas
à la légère un jeune non personne est-ce
que tu connais en moi la personne au
bout la balade la jeune fille non désolé
je connais personne en fait c'est un
traitement encore j'aime beaucoup qui
lui
fait appel il obstacles pas parce que tu
appelles en vrai inès inès fait qu'ils
naissent pour un garçon c'est pas comme
ça revient très fort
jeudi renvoi ils m'appellent jacqueline
passent
des fois c'était galère au début en
chinois centré non mais c'est vrai ça
j'appelle habitués et après tu t'es
coupeau tout le monde appelait inox
parce que tu n'en ferais tout mon peuple
est nette mais moi je me suis dit knoxy
naissent sa passe était comme inox à
rentrer pas sur internet voit déjà des
gens qui l'avaient halimi tag ce que
j'ai mais des fois qu'ils étaient pas
exactement taxe
pas possible j'adore cette chanson
bilingue en espagnol
en fait c'est parce que j'étais au
mexique avec mes amis
c'est parce que j'étais au mexique avec
mes amis et j'ai rencontré une fille qui
est venue et elle a dit j'ai une méduse
qui m'a piqué non si dans d'autres
villes elle est venue gl et à la mer et
le minuscule à 9 et u connaissais pas
alors je connaissais pas ouais et à mes
potes ils ont dit on va organiser en
baisse avec elle mais moi je voulais moi
non sinon ça va être ma maison et tout
en plus il faut sucer quand la méduse
[Applaudissements]
donc oui on me disait eynden et qu'ils
ont nouée sur la chaîne youtube ils
l'ont filmé alors et support des bons
délires un vrai bon délire sans passé
mais c'était pour rire c'est cool quoi
et alors non il ya eu un bayou bas elle
veut revenir en décembre ah ouais
mais 12 à paris
j'ai essayé en effet directement sur les
grands boulevards
[Rires]
aussi j'ai eu peur je suis pas venu je
suis parti très loin de vous est ce que
je voulais pas me faire cogner en tant
qu ils responsables est ce que vous
voulez le cogner jean paul and away
alors ça ça vraiment
j'adore dans les abords si vous voulez
vous avez posé une question je vais y
répondre c'est un matin à matin de bonne
heure dimanche matin j'étais interviewé
sur une surgelés
pas fabrice division
division étaient à la messe et donc il
n'a pas entendu ce que j'ai dit est donc
effectivement
non je peux remplacer
donc
c'était quand même très énervé sûr pour
les gens qui ont refusé de se faire
vacciner et
et donc là j'ai dit une phrase il va
falloir il va falloir sortir la boîte à
claques perso je me tape un vrai succès
chez les patriots après avoir dit sur
cette liste il fallait sortir la boîte à
claques pour les non vaccinés bravo
alors ça c'est pas de la violence ça me
fait rire parce que pour l'instant le
signalions cher m vous pouvez vous la
mettre d'accord
la samah la saba m
[Musique]
il est supposé nous représenter
première chaîne d'europe il est supposé
nous représenter voilà est-ce que ce
garçon représente mais vous allez vous
renoncer
une chose que je voudrais dire c'est que
bilal ils ne représentent pas les gays
mais oui en gros la seule chose qu'il
faut retenir c'est que bilal il serait
prise sur lui
parce que c'est un artiste dans une
émission de variétés de divertissement
et en gros il se représente lui il a
envie de s'habiller comme il veut il le
fait et il va montrer à des jeunes qui
regardent la télé est peut-être à des
parents qui se moquent catastrophé non
mais je te le dis alors moi je te le dis
mais tu te regardent moins la tradition
sociologique que ton sec et très belle
je rêve dans la vraie vie tu sais ce que
ça va donner jma donner des gens
arrivent on est devant leur télévision a
qui vont se dire ma bishop's et les
guerres les goulags et ça va créer de la
violence et sont l'allemagne la
différence ce qu'ils sont mais europe et
en enrayant fossé non
mais c'est quoi
on se maquille
les québécois gay c'est plein de choses
pour qu'on prend forcément oui on allait
d'automne celui qui établiront le passé
avec une robe aussi
c'est en fait on a besoin de victoires a
besoin de diversité mais on a peur c'est
normal il était en train de dire que les
gays c'est différent on essaie de faire
ensemble qui est de moins en moins de
moncton be on essaie de faire un sans
diffuseur et donner leurs noms étaient
assez complet on montre des quartiers
donc vous avez saisi l'ordre des
gynécologues
l'ordre des gynécologues et
obstétriciens un abord ce que je
voudrais rappeler ce qui est important
c'est que ce qu'a dit cette influence
euse a des conséquences et je pense que
quand on est entendu et regardé par des
enfants et des adolescents on a une
responsabilité liège en tongs et pas du
tout d'accord ah mais non mais là
faudrait qu'elle réalisait la faux sur
toute la ligne marne n'échappe à elle
dénonce je cite le fait de promouvoir
des pratiques chirurgicales alors déjà
il ya aucune promotion c'était pas un
placement de produit c'était jeanne
story dans laquelle elle filme et sa vie
et ensuite pratiques chirurgicales non
il n'y a pas eu d'opération elle a
simplement fait une eau une épilation
qui s'est mal passé lc rigged rappelle
qu'après un mois je pense qu'elle veut
faire que de la forme c'est à dire du
buzz en s'attaquant à une candidate qui
est très populaire sur les réseaux
sociaux au détriment du fond et sans
s'intéresser au fond la moindre des
choses serait de se renseigner sur les
soirs elle donne des informations qu'on
prend quoi qu'elle est dans le cabinet
d'un chirurgien d'un médecin et qui
cautionnent ce type de pratique c'est ça
le message que ça envoie et ça c'est ça
qui le fait que cette personne le fasse
oui c'est sa liberté elle fait ce
qu'elle veut par contre le message
qu'elle fait passer là il ya une
responsable italienne responsabilité
pour moi pour le metalab raconter ce
qu'elle veut c'est pas une femme
politique j'ai pas dit le contraire j'ai
pas dit qu'elle n'avait pas le grandes
firmes se défend la liberté d'expression
mais je pense qu'on est responsable
aussi moralement du message qu'on envoie
à des gamines de 12 ans à des enfants
très jeunes qui vont entendre ça et
qu'ils vont se dire ah mais en fait je
suis pas normal ou bien on fait
peut-être le vent me faire opérer c'est
assez grave
beaucoup ont vaincu par le casting de
dalles ce
[Applaudissements]
4 juillet selon ça perso
4g de balades dans les bois et l'oignon
paul gaultier il a pris quatre cent
mille euros dita von teese 120000 euros
ou wade n 60 milles à peu près entre 70
et 80 minutes ce qui paraît il à la
sagne et michaux taux de 60 milles et le
reste auprès de 30 mai 530000 et 50000
fort au regard des mérites regardez vous
et c'est très bien
bessalah il est arrivé là détaillants
mais c'est parce que
c'est ça c'est en brut ça alors excuse
moi explique ce fait les cheveux
le sondage complet qu'est ce que les
téléspectateurs sont convaincus par
la la c'est en plus un peu le mazembe
bible dans madame est compliqué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]